it's from the daily wire it says um well
first of all thursday night was the um
the congressional
baseball game where
republicans won 10-0
and which is which is pretty funny
already of course it was only five years
ago that republicans were attacked
during a baseball during a baseball game
by a crazed bernie bro who went there
with a hit list
intent on murdering gop lawmakers
and um so you might think that given
that history that this would be
you know a congressional baseball game
is a time for displays of unity and
brotherly love
you might think that if you're brain
damaged but if not you're not surprised
to see this representative linda sanchez
uh democrat from california
after i believe striking out we can only
assume
she's uh walking by the gop dugout and
then she does this let's play this clip
here she as she flips them off as she
walks by lead off the inning we'll get a
pinch runner down there the fist bump
we'll get an eye on who the pinch runner
is going to be looks like it's going to
be jeffries
[Applause]
and she will come off to a nice ovation
well not much reaction from the
okay
so
okay i might have been on fair tour i
guess i i take from the context there
that she she did she did get a hit but
then she had a pinch she has someone
running for her she has a pinch runner
no big surprise there
but she she goes by the dugout and she
just flips off the republicans
i mean this is like this is a lawmaker
right this is someone who's suppose
there was a time when you expected
there's never been a time when when
politics was anything but a rough and
tumble sport but there was a time when
you would expect
some measure of
decorum and dignity and statesmanship
from your elected leaders
even when they were pummeling each other
over the head when you know when
arguments in congress became physically
violent
still there was some dignity and decorum
to it
now we just don't expect that at all so
it's not a surprise to see that but
here's her excuse from the daily wire
she said says democrat representative
linda sanchez claimed in a statement
friday afternoon that she flipped off
the republican dugout during thursday
night's congressional baseball game
because she heard a sexist remark being
made as she ran back to the democrats
dugout
the statement read the congressional
baseball game is one of my favorite
events of the year it's a great cause
and brings both sides of the aisle
together for a night off from partisan
politics that's why it really struck a
nerve when i heard an offensive and
misogynistic comment from the republican
side on my way back to the dugout
so there was a it was an offensive and
misogynistic comment that was made to
her she doesn't say what the comment was
and i guess being very charitable she
never meant she never says who who said
it
well this excuse didn't really land and
that's why a day later
she clarified the story yet again this
is from red state it says now sanchez is
clarifying her story again she's now
saying it wasn't the republican team
that made the comment
she says quote it wasn't the team it was
an obnoxious fan who shouts misogynistic
s at me every single year
but she still went after republicans she
says actually they you know she's the
victim here she says if the republican
women would have stood up and said
that's not accep acceptable instead of
you know trashing me for my response
then we might have a place where there's
no misogyny that's tolerated by anybody
anywhere
and yet amid all these excuses that
she's offering
uh she still has not she's not told us
what the comment was
and she even says well it wasn't now it
wasn't it wasn't the republican
wasn't the actual republicans themselves
it was someone on their side up in the
in the stands who made the comment but
she knows who the guy is
because she says he's there every year
but very nice of her to not mention his
name
because democrats are known for that
right of course
they're very reticent to throw anybody
under the bus to name names to send the
outrage mob after anybody no they never
do that kind of thing
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
that wall show if you did be sure to
subscribe to this youtube channel and
click the notification button to get
more content like this if you want to
watch or listen to the full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe today you
can also listen to my podcast on spotify
apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcasts